[Música]
el presidente de ucrania volodymyr
selenski dice haber visto señales
positivas tras la reunión de este martes
entre representantes de moscú y kiev en
estambul rusia se compromete a reducir
su actividad en torno a kiev la capital
y en chernin hiv mientras que la
delegación ucraniana afirmó tener la
voluntad para declararse como un estado
neutral
occidente recibe los resultados de las
negociaciones con cautela eeuu francia
alemania reino unido e italia abogan por
no bajar la guardia veremos si cumplen
afirmó el presidente joe biden mientras
que el pentágono advierte que cree que
no hay una retirada de las tropas rusas
sino un reposicionamiento
el presidente mexicano andrés manuel
lópez obrador negó que su administración
esté ocultando información respecto al
caso de los 43 estudiantes de ayotzinapa
desaparecidos en 2014 de acuerdo con el
mandatario los jefes de la marina que
participaron en las primeras pesquisas
están siendo investigados en medio de
acusaciones de manipulación de pruebas
un momento para actuar las noticias en
francés 24 gracias por permanecer con
nosotros yo soy juan pupiales
comenzamos con el conflicto entre rusia
y ucrania el presidente ucraniano
volodymyr selenski dice haber visto
señales positivas tras el encuentro de
cerca de cuatro horas que delegaciones
de kiev y moscú celebraron en estambul
turquía rusia se comprometió a reducir
radicalmente dicen su actividad
alrededor de kiev la capital y de
chernin hiv una ciudad al norte del país
por su parte la representación ucraniana
afirmó tener la voluntad de declararse
como un estado neutral algo que frenaría
sus aspiraciones para unirse a la otan
que es uno de los reclamos de rusia
si podemos decir que las señales que
escuchamos de las conversaciones son
positivas pero estas señales no pueden
silenciar las explosiones de los
proyectiles rusos maxim o sí dreizik y
por supuesto estamos viendo todos los
riesgos por supuesto no vemos motivos
para confiar en las palabras que vienen
de los representantes del país que sigue
luchando para destruirnos sara de nación
luís las potencias occidentales
reaccionaron con cautela a las
conclusiones de las negociaciones entre
rusia y ucrania
eeuu francia alemania reino unido italia
abogan por que moscú siga pagando el
precio de su intervención militar los
líderes de estas naciones mantuvieron
este martes una conversación telefónica
aseguraron que no puede haber una
distensión en su determinación contra el
horror que vive el pueblo ucraniano por
su parte el pentágono advirtió que cree
que los recientes movimientos de las
tropas rusas pueden no ser una retirada
sino un reposicionamiento
antes de que el rápido avance hacia aquí
en los primeros días de la guerra nos
mostró muy claramente a todos que quiere
la capital será un objetivo clave para
los rusos así que no deberíamos ser
engañados y nadie debería engañarse a sí
mismo por la afirmación reciente del
kremlin de que de repente reducirá los
ataques militares cerca de kiev o
cualquier informe de que va a retirar
todas sus fuerzas
el mariupol todavía no hay claridad
sobre el alcance de los daños allí unas
100.000 personas siguen viviendo en la
ciudad enormemente destruida y en medio
del asedio de las fuerzas rusas nuestros
colegas de fans realizaron este
reportaje desde el interior de la zona
la pulverizada mariupol parece un pueblo
fantasma pudimos entrar en una parte de
la ciudad donde fuimos escoltados por
fuerzas rusas y separatistas ahora
tienen el control aquí ninguna casa o
edificio parece haberse librado del
fuego cruzado en las calles vacías
algunos residentes deambulan
desorientados como este hombre con la
cara cubierta de hollín
a dónde vas vuelvo a mi casa
pero allí no queda ninguna casa
todavía queda es el vecino
parece que ya no oye los bombardeos en
la distancia
la electricidad la calefacción el agua
están bordadas desde hace casi un mes
los que quedan como oksana viven
hacinados en el subsuelo
ahora somos 50 personas los bombardeos
dan mucho miedo las condiciones de vida
son nefastas hay polvo por todas partes
las mujeres y los niños duermen en estos
colchones habían días en los que no
teníamos nada que comer dábamos a los
niños galletas o lo que tuviéramos ahora
el frente se ha movido podemos salir
pero solo para cocinar
un poco más lejos de donde se refugia
oksana esto es lo que queda del teatro
de mariupol fue aquí en el sótano donde
se refugiaron varios cientos de civiles
estas imágenes fueron tomadas por un
canal de televisión ruso no muestra
ningún cuerpo dentro de lo que queda del
edificio donde se teme que murieron 300
personas en un solo ataque ruso cerca de
una de las salidas de la ciudad los
residentes huyen de la devastación los
soldados separatistas registran a todos
los que salen los hombres deben quitarse
las camisas esto es para demostrar que
no están luchando por ucrania es para
que los ss no huyan todos los de los
batallones ultranacionalistas tienen
tatuajes de las ss familias enteras se
van muchas de ellas con lo poco que aún
tienen y estoy muy cansado y mis
juguetes no tienen batería las ventanas
de nuestra casa explotaron
y en casa de los abuelos y de mi amigo
el apartamento se quemó todo se quemó
vamos que
ya no
es
la casa de esta mujer también se quemó
nos cuenta que se lleva todo lo que le
queda el presidente de méxico andrés
manuel lópez obrador negó los
señalamientos en forma independiente que
asegura que el gobierno está ocultando
información en torno a la desaparición
de los 43 estudiantes de ayotzinapa en
2014 según el mandatario los jefes de la
marina que participaron en un supuesto
operativo secreto están siendo
investigados
a casi 8 años de la desaparición de los
43 estudiantes de ayotzinapa el caso
vuelve a abrir las heridas en mexico
tras la presentación del tercer informe
del grupo interdisciplinario de expertos
independientes que culpa el gobierno de
ocultar información clave y denuncia a
miembros de la marina por participar en
un operativo secreto para alterar
pruebas el presidente de méxico andrés
manuel lópez obrador negó las
acusaciones y aseguró que investiga los
señalados se dio la instrucción
de s
investigara
los jefes de marina que participaron en
ese operativo y ya han declarado los
investigadores revelaron al menos 50
vídeos inéditos como prueba de lo que
sucedió horas después de la desaparición
de los jóvenes en uno de ellos se ve a
infantes de marina supuestamente
alterando la escena del basurero de
cocula lugar donde los normalistas
habrían sido asesinados y quemados el
informe también asegura que las
autoridades regionales y nacionales le
hacían seguimiento a los estudiantes por
lo que estuvieron al tanto de lo que
sucedía antes durante y después de la
desaparición ante estas pruebas tardías
los familiares expresaron su decepción y
cansancio si da coraje da mucho coraje
de verdad de ver que esas instituciones
del gobierno federal han tenido y siguen
aguardando verdad más información
distintos ocultaron esto que más pueden
ocultar
el que miente una vez bien de dos veces
o tres veces según la llamada verdad
histórica versión ofrecida por el
gobierno de enrique peña nieto- los 43
estudiantes fueron secuestrados y
entregados al cartel de herreros unidos
cuando se movilizaban para participar en
una protesta hasta el momento los restos
de sólo tres de los jóvenes han sido
identificados en eeuu la administración
de alimentos y medicamentos la fda y los
centros para el control y prevención de
enfermedades cdc anunciaron este martes
la aprobación de una segunda dosis de
refuerzo de la vacuna contra el coi 19
para personas mayores de 50 años
luz verde para una cuarta dosis de la
vacuna contra el cob y 19 así lo
anunciaron los reguladores de salud
estadounidenses para personas mayores de
50 años hoy la administración de
alimentos y medicamentos de los estados
unidos autorizó una segunda dosis de
refuerzo de las vacunas contra el kobe
19 the fighter iv by antec o moderna
para personas mayores y ciertas personas
inmunodeprimidas la agencia había
aprobado la aplicación de un segundo
refuerzo sólo para personas mayores de
12 años con la dosis de facer y más 18
con modernas que tuvieran el sistema
inmunitario debilitado quienes ahora
incluso podrán acceder a una quinta
dosis desde la casa blanca aplaudieron
el anuncio
es algo bueno que los cdc y la fda ahora
lo permitan vamos a poner a disposición
para las personas mayores de 50 años y
para los inmunodeprimidos una cuarta
dosis tenemos suficientes vacunas para
que la población de esa edad pueda
vacunarse mensual
es una noticia que ha generado opiniones
divididas entre los estadounidenses
cuando sacaran una vacuna de verdad una
en la que te coloquen una o dos dosis y
ya en nuestros continuos refuerzos creo
que hay algo aquí que no está bien
y sí creo que es bueno prefiero estar
protegida lo más que pueda tuve kobe y
fue terrible y entonces no quiero
tenerlo nuevamente
el anuncio se da en medio de una
temporada donde los casos por kobe 19
han disminuido y luego de que el país se
enfrentaron de positivos por la variante
omicron al momento el país registra más
de 80 millones de contagios y más de 970
mil muertes
quédense en 324
[Música]